Hey, Vsauce2, Michael here, and this is episode
2 of BOAT.
This one covers weird celebrity body things
that make you say WTF, and, I did it with
my friends over at Barely Political.
So, this video is part 2 of the two-parter-
we've got that many.
So, click here to go check out part 1 on Barely
Political, and I'll see you back here for
the rest of the Body WTF's.
Welcome back.
The answer to the question: Kate Hudson...but
not really.
Actually, her things is that all of her toes
are so shifted to the right that she's got
all this extra foot, and it makes it look
like a 6th toe from certain angles.
"Extra foot?"
"I was actually thinking that if celebrities
are doing it, I was gonna get a toe-implant
on my right foot."
"Yeah, I was gonna say, 6 toes- that's 5 more
toes than good movies usually have in it."
(Laughter)
"I don't even get that!"
Oh, but this, look guys, I'm gonna kill the
mood with Tina Fey's story.
You've seen this scar before.
It's got the weirdest story.
When she was 5 years old she was cut but a
stranger.
Just came up to her, cut, left.
I don't think the ever even caught the guy.
It's like Bed Intruder but really sad...
Denzel Washington broke his finger when he
was a kid playing basketball and he never
had it reset.
So, as you can see, he's got a nice little
crookedness to it.
"This one.
Him and I are twins."
"It did not effect his jump shot in "He Got
Game."
Guys, look, it's about time for us to start
talking about third nipples- Lily Allen and
Mark Wahlberg both have them.
And in this video clip she shows it off.
Look at that little guy.
Here's my question: do I sensor that?
I don't think I do.
"It looks like a birthmark."
"I love her."
Well, Mark Wahlberg has one and I guess I
don't have to sensor him.
Carrie Underwood also used to have a third
nipple, but had it removed.
Lame.
"She had it donated to Mark Wahlberg."
So now he's got 4.
It's part of his plan to become like a pig.
Remember in Happy Gilmore where Bob Barker
totally punches out Adam Sandler?
That whole fight there was not a single stunt
double for Bob Barker, he trained in karate.
Guess with who.
"Bruce Lee?"
Chuck Norris.
Bob Barker and Chuck Norris worked together.
Bob still has it- check out what he does to
Craig Ferguson's desk.
This was just like, 3 or 4 years ago.
'Cause no one believes me!
"This is when Bob Barker was 106."
"Whaaaat"
"He had the skinniest microphone, the girliest
microphone of all time, and he just chopped
a desk in half??"
Thanks for watching there at home, thanks
for coming to Vsauce2.
Be sure to subscribe for more BOAT and a show
called Lüt where you can buy everything that
I cover in there.
So, anyway, thanks for watching, thank you
guys for helping me cover the fact that celebrities
are just as weird as everybody...if not weirder.
And, as always ("I didn't know that"), thanks
for watching.
Ok, hey guys, I promised that I would show
you my weird thing.
Look at your hand, and then when you look
at your hand and you crease it like this,
do you see two lines?
Probably, because you're a normal homo sapien.
But, on my left hand, when i crimp it down,
I've got one line.
It's called a Simian line, and I think it
means my DNA is more like a monkey.
So...hooray?